in den kommenden wochen werden wir der
ukraine eng abgestimmt mit den
niederländern 12 der modernsten
panzerhaubitzen der welt liefern die
ausbildung ukrainischer soldaten daran
wird in wenigen tagen abgeschlossen sein
und es sind wirklich sehr moderne waffen
sehr schwere waffen was soll abgesehen
davon dass das abschießen von flugzeugen
mit luftabwehrraketen auch ein schwerer
vorgang ist was anderes schwerer macht
sein hoch schwere waffen man kann damit
so in der gegend rum schließen manchmal
hört man tatsächlich noch aus dass olaf
scholz zivildienst gemacht hat und nicht
wirklich weiß was in der bundeswehr los
ist und was danach waffentechnik ist gut
wir machen viel lernen auch neue worte
von kanzler
in den kommenden wochen werden wir der
ukraine eng abgestimmt mit den
niederländern
wenn wir den kommenden wochen werden wir
auch weitere waffen liefern zum beispiel
hat die bundesregierung aktuell
entschieden dass wir mit dem system iris
t das modernste flugabwehrsystem liefern
über das deutschland verfügt damit
versetzen die die ukraine in die lage
eine ganze großstadt vor russischen
luftangriffen zu schützen auch das ist
eine entscheidung dieser bundesregierung
ferner werden wir in der ukraine ein
hochmodernes ortungs radar liefern das
feindliche auf pizzen mörsern und
raketen artillerie aufklärt auch das ist
eine entscheidung die wir getroffen
haben und die die sicherheit der ukraine
mit modernstem gerät sicherstellen wird
alles was sie sagen ist nicht richtig
wir machen das was mögliches allen
regionen
[Applaus]